the final episode of one division
has arrived this place
this is our home
and no one will ever take it from me
again
i have everything under control
are you sure
marvel studios one division all episodes
[Music]
[Music]
original series now streaming only on
disney plus
[Music]
we are an unusual couple it was really
so fun getting to play all these
different decades
throughout juan division we just don't
know what to expect
and then of course everything kind of
breaks down and becomes an mcu version
of the real world
am i dead no why would you think that
because you are can't believe how it
just
keeps unraveling and unfolding in ways
that i
am still shocked and thrilled by
every day it's something different you
know it's high-tech marvel with
helicopters flying around
and the next day it's a perfect
recreation of a 50s sitcom you know some
days it's it's both
i think something's wrong here
[Applause]
i think it's gonna be really satisfying
for people when they realize
what is at the heart of this show this
is our home
then let's fight for it
[Applause]
you